so
uh now that we've spoken about why 42 uh
why do we search for meaning and uh
you're asking you know will that search
ultimately lead to our destruction and
my my thinking is exactly the opposite
so basically that
asking about meaning is something that's
so
inherent to human nature it's something
that makes life beautiful
that makes it worth living and that
searching for meaning
is actually the point it's not defining
it i think when you found it you're dead
don't don't ever be satisfied that you
know i've got it
so i like to say that life is lived
forward
but it only makes sense backward and i
don't remember whose quote that is
but the the the whole search itself
is the meaning and what i love about it
is that
there's a double search going on there's
a search in
every one of us through our own lives to
find meaning
and then there's a search which is
happening for humanity itself
to find our meaning and
we as humans like to look at animals and
say of course they have a meaning
like a dog has its meaning it's just a
bunch of instincts
you know running around loving
everything um
you know remember a joke with a cat in
the dark yeah
no no so so um and
i i'm noticing the yin yang symbol right
here with this whole panda
black and white and the zero one zero
one five with that 42. some of those are
gold
ascii value for uh the star symbol
damn anyway so so basically in my view
the the search for meaning and the act
of
uh searching for something more
meaningful
is life's meaning
by itself but the fact that we kind of
always hope that yes maybe for animals
that's not the case
but maybe humans have something that we
should be doing
and something else and it's not just
about procreation it's not just about
dominance it's not just about strength
and feeding et cetera
like we're the one species that spends
such a tiny little minority of its time
feeding that we have this enormous
you know huge cognitive capability
that we can just use for all kinds of
other stuff and that's where
art comes in that's where you know the
healthy mind
comes in with you know exploring all of
these different aspects that are just
not
directly tied to um
to a purpose that's not directly tied to
a function it's really just the
the playing of life the you know
not not for particular reason
you